hardline protesters rally outside the
British Embassy in Tehran the British
spy must be expelled they chant they're
referring to the UK's ambassador who was
arrested by Iran in a diplomatic attack
Rob macare was accused of attending an
illegal gathering a charge he denies the
ambassador was quickly released but
summoned today to the foreign ministry
we believe that the actions yesterday
with the Ambassador were breach of the
Vienna Convention totally unacceptable
UN does need to step back from that kind
of activity and play a proper part in
working with partners little sign of
that
judging by be seems they hold posters of
a top Iranian general killed in a US
drone strike only small-scale for now
they're bound to prompt fears of a
repeat of 2011 rioters stormed the
embassy forcing its closure the mission
only reopened five years ago as London
and Tehran worked to mend ties but it's
an increasingly fort time for Iran amid
its standoff with America its forces
have just admitted to shooting down a
Ukrainian passenger jet after days of
denial this newspaper headline reads
shame it fueled protests of a different
kind
these ones against the government and
seemingly favorable towards the United
States President Donald Trump urged
Iran's leaders don't kill your
protestors thousands have already been
killed or imprisoned by you and the
world is watching in Ukraine officials
are watching to see how Iran deals with
the plane tragedy how did its
Revolutionary Guard mistake a passenger
jet for a missile it's overshadowed
Iran's attempt to avenge the killing of
Major General Qasem Soleimani in your
opinion given that Iran had just
launched military strikes across the
border against us targets in Iraq with
their air defenses have been on
particularly high
that night whoops don't look you've got
Olynyk ideally in the condition Iran was
in at that time where the IRGC and
military forces were in a very tense
state waiting for the u.s. to respond
tensions will have been increasing and
there's the real possibility of making
huge mistakes in these moments Iran's
leaders will be feeling under pressure
this could make them more sensitive than
usual to domestic dissent and to
ambassadors who fall out of favor
Deborah Haines Sky News Kiev